The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I guess we're all
set for getting close to
the end, coming now to a race
about whether we could say
anything meaningful about
Martingales or not.
But I think we can.
I want to spend a little time
reviewing the Wald identity
today and also sequential
tests.
It turns out that last
time on the slides--
I didn't get the thresholds
confused--
I got hypothesis 0 and
hypothesis 1 interchanged from
the way we usually do them.
And it doesn't make
any difference.
There's no difference between
hypothesis 0 and hypothesis 1.
And you can do it either
way you want to.
But it gets very confusing when
you switch from one to
the other when you're halfway
through an argument.
So I'm going to go through
part of that again today.
And we will get revised slides
on the web, so that if you
want to see them with the
hypotheses done in a
consistent way, you
will see it there.
That should be on there by
this afternoon I hope.
OK, so let's go on and review
what Mr. Wald said.
He was talking about
a random walk.
Random walk consists of a bunch
of a sequence of IID
random variables.
The random walk consists of the
sequence of partial sums
of those random variables.
And the question is if this
random walk is taking place
and you have two thresholds, one
at alpha and one of beta--
and beta is below 0 and
alpha is above 0--
and you start at 0, of course,
and the question is when do
you cross one of these two
thresholds and which
threshold do cross?
What's the probability of
crossing each other, and
everything else you can say
about this problem.
And it turns out this is a very
major problem as far as
stochastic processes are
concerned, because it comes up
almost everywhere.
It certainly comes up as far as
hypothesis testing is concerned.
It's probably the major problem
there when you get
into sequential analysis.
It's the major problem there.
So it's a very important
problem.
And what Wald said was if you
let the random variable J be
the stopping time of this random
walk, namely, the time
in which the walk first crosses
either alpha or
crosses the beta, and then he
said no matter what r you
choose and the range of points
where the moment generating
function g sub X of r exists.
Y You can pick any r in that
range, and then what you get
is this strange looking
equality here.
And I pointed out last time it
just wasn't all that strange,
because if instead of using the
stopping time of when you
cross a threshold, if instead
you used as a stopping time
just some particular end.
You go for some number of steps,
and then you stop.
And at that point, you
have the expected
value of E to the rsn.
The expected value of E to the
rsn by definition is the
moment generating function at r
of S sub n, which is exactly
equal to the minus J times
gamma n times gamma of r.
So all we're doing here,
all that Wald did--
as it turns out, it
was quite a bit--
was to say that when you replace
a fixed end with a
stopping time, you still
get the same result.
We're stating it here just for
the case of two thresholds.
Wald stated it in much
general terms.
We'll use it a more general
terms, when we say more about
martingales.
X, now remember is the
underlying random variable.
S sub n is the sum of the X's.
If X bar is less than 0, and
if gamma r star equals 0, r
star is the r at which
gamma of r equals 0.
It's the second root
of gamma of r.
Gamma of r, if you remember,
looks like this.
This is r star here.
This is the expected value
of X as the slope here.
And we're assuming that X bar
is less than 0 for this.
I don't know how that greater
than 0 got in.
And then what it says is the
probability that SJ is greater
than or equal to alpha is less
than or equal to the minus
alpha r star.
And last time, remember, we
went through a long, messy
bunch of equations for that.
I looked at it again, and this
is just the simple old Markov
inequality again.
All you do to get this is you
say, OK, think of the random
variable, E to the r SJ.
SJ is a very complicated random
variable, but it's a
random variable, nonetheless.
So either the rSJ is a random
variable and the expected
value of that random variable
is at r star, the expected
value of it is just one.
I'll write down.
It'll be easier.
The expected value e to the r
star S sub J is equal to 1.
And therefore, the probability
that E to the r star SJ is a
greater than or equal to E to
the r star alpha is just less
than or equal to 1 over E
to the r star alpha, OK?
And that's what the
inequality says.
So that's all there is to it.
OK, what?
AUDIENCE: I don't really see
why these two [INAUDIBLE]?
They don't [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You need x1 negative
so that you get
another root so that
r star exists.
If r star is positive, if the
expected value of x is
positive, then r star is down
here at negative r.
I mean, you're talking
about the other
threshold in a sense.
OK, this is valid for all
lower thresholds.
And it's also valid
for no threshold.
OK, in other words, this
equation here does not have
beta in it at all.
So this equation is an upper
bound on the probability, that
you're going to cross that
threshold of alpha.
And that upper bound is valid,
no matter where you put the
lower bound at all.
So you can go to the
limit as the lower
bound goes to infinity.
And this inequality should
still be valid.
You have a homework problem
where you actually prove that.
Sometimes when things go to
infinity, funny things happen.
And that proves that nothing
funny happens then.
So what happens then is the
probability that you ever
cross a threshold at plus alpha,
when you have a random
variable, which has a negative
mean, is this exponent here.
And we also sort of showed by
looking at the turn off bound
that this bound is
pretty tight.
So in other words, what this
is saying is when you're
looking at threshold
crossing problems--
this quantity here, this
quantity where the second root
of gamma of r is--
that's sort of the
crucial parameter
that you want to know.
Usually the first thing you want
to know about a random
variable is its mean, its
variance, all sorts
of things like that.
This is saying if you're
interested in thresholds,
forget about all those things,
look at r star.
If r star is positive that means
it means is negative, so
there's no problem there.
But this one quantity here is
sort of the most important
parameter of all of
these problems.
OK, so let's go back to look at
a hypothesis testing again,
where we're looking at the
likelihood ratio of being the
ratio of the density for
hypothesis 0 divided by
hypothesis 1.
What you get then is you observe
this sequence Y sub n.
These are the observations
that you're taking.
In other words, nature at the
beginning of this whole
experiment chooses either H
equals 0 or H equals 1.
At that point, you start
to make measurements.
Now whether nature chooses H
equals 0 before or after or
when doesn't make
any difference.
The point is the experiment
consists of nature choosing
one of these two hypotheses.
You know all the probabilities
that exist in the world in
this model.
You go making these
measurements.
All you of observe is
these measurements.
You don't observe what the
hypothesis is, so you define
this likelihood ratio of the
ratio of the densities of the
vector Y for H equals 0 and the
vector Y with H equals 1.
These quantities exist no
matter what the a priori
probabilities of the thresholds
are or anything else.
Even without all of that, so
long as you have a model which
tells you what the densities
of these observations are,
conditional on each hypothesis,
you can define this.
This doesn't depend on a priori
probabilities at all.
OK, so now you look at the
probability that H is equal to
0, given all these observations
divided by the
probability it's equal to 1.
What you get here now,
you have the a priori
probabilities, p0 over p1.
Here is the likelihood
ratio here.
So what you have this p0 over p1
times the likelihood ratio
of this vector of however many
observations you have observed.
It's just a nice way of breaking
up the problem into
the likelihood ratio and the
a priori probabilities.
Incidentally, we haven't talked
about this at all, but
there's an important idea and
all of this hypothesis testing
of a sufficient statistic, and
what do you think a sufficient
statistic is.
It's anything from which
you can calculate
the likelihood ratio.
In other words, what we're
saying here, the point we're
making, is that any intelligent
choice of
hypothesis is it based on
a threshold test on the
likelihood ratio.
And therefore, the only thing
you can really be interested
in in all your observations
is just what is
the likelihood ratio?
If they make all these 1,000
observations complicated sort
of thing, you calculate
one number.
And that's the only thing
you're interested in.
And anything from which that
number could be calculated is
a sufficient statistic.
And anything from which it can't
be calculated you've
thrown away some of the
information that you have.
If you study communication and
you study detection, you study
how to receive data that's being
sent, what you find is
that right at the beginning,
even before you do any
detection, even before you do
any filtering, there's some
idea of a sufficient
statistic there.
That's what you need in order to
calculate everything else.
And you want to make sure
that you have that.
So that's an important
idea there.
OK, but anyway, the MAP rule,
which comes right from this,
says if you have these a priori
probabilities, and
you're trying to maximize the
probability of choosing
correctly, what do you do?
Well, your probability of H
equals 0 was the correct
hypothesis, given all
the observations you
made, is in fact this.
The probability that H equals
1 is the correct
hypothesis is this.
What do you do if you want to
maximize the probability of
being correct?
You choose the one
which is biggest.
In other words, what you do is
you look at this number.
And if this number is bigger
than 1, you choose 0.
If it's less than 1, you
choose hypothesis 1.
And what it turns out to
is threshold of rule.
You take this likelihood
ratio.
You compare it with
p1 over p0.
And in this case, you
select h equals 0.
In this case you select
H equals 1.
And the last time I just a 1 and
0 reversed, which is fine,
but if you reverse them one
place, you want a reverse them
every place.
And every other threshold test
does something like this,
except you replace p1 over p0
with some arbitrary threshold.
You say whatever reason you
want to find for that
threshold, that's the only
intelligent kind of
test you can make.
OK, then we define the
log-likelihood ratio of the
logarithm of the likelihood
ratio.
And that was nice because it
was a sum of this quantity
related to the individual
observations.
For each observation you really
want to know what f of
Y given H of Y given 0,
divided by Y given 1.
You want to divide those two.
You want to take the
logarithm of it.
And then you have those numbers,
and the sufficient
statistic that you're interested
in is just a sum of
those numbers.
So you're looking at a sum
of IID, random variable.
IID, why IID?
Well, under the hypothesis that
H is equal to 1, those
Yi's are IID.
And therefore under the
hypothesis that
H is equal to 1.
Well, little Zi is just
a sample value.
If you look at the random
variable which has these
sampled values, Z sub i, under
the probability measure,
corresponding to H equals 1,
those Z sub i's are IID.
So what that says is when you
look at these sums of random
variables, the sum of Zi from
1 to n, under hypothesis H
equals 1, what do you get?
You get a random walk.
You get a sum of IID
random variables.
If you take more observations,
S sub n just changes.
With n changing, then you
have a larger number of
observations.
So the random walk goes a little
further out, and you
might get closer to a threshold
or whatever.
And that's what we're
trying to do here.
OK, so the Z sub i's under the
hypothesis H equals 1, or IID,
and the moment generating
function of the Z sub i's
given H equals 1, is this.
Let's be careful about this.
The sampled values of the Z
sub i do not depend on the
hypotheses at all.
Namely, you make
an observation.
You make an observation
of Y sub i.
You calculate Z sub
i from Y sub i.
That has nothing to do
with whether H equals
0 or H equals 1.
You try to calculate
this moment
generating function, however.
And you want to know what
the probability
density of the Y's are.
And you get a different
probability density for H
equals 1, then you get on
the other hypothesis.
If the observations behaved
the same way under both
hypotheses, it wouldn't make
much sense to do the
observation.
Unless you have a government
grant, and you're trying to
get money out of the government
instead of trying
to do anything worthwhile.
Under those circumstances, you
keep on making observations.
You now perfectly well
that nothing is going
to come from them.
But otherwise, it's
a little silly.
So this moment generating
function under the hypothesis
H equals 1 is given by
this quantity here.
And this density here is the
same as this density here.
So you get this density to the
1 minus r power, and you get
this density to the r power.
So you get the product of
these two densities.
You integrate it over Y, and
that's what gamma 1 of r is.
Now I said that the really
important thing in all of
these threshold problems
is what is our star?
And for this problem,
r star is trivial.
It's always the same.
r star is always equal to 1.
And the reason is when you set
r equal to 1 here, this
quantity becomes 1.
This quantity becomes
the density of Y
conditional on H equals 0.
When you integrate
that, you get 1.
So for all of these hypothesis
testing problems, r star is
equal to 1.
Gamma 1 of 1 is equal to 0.
And this is what this
curve says.
OK, this is gamma 1 of r here.
This curve starts out here,
negative slope.
It comes up here.
r star is equal to
1 in this case.
And that's sort of the end
of the story for that.
Now if you are doing a test with
a fixed value of n, you
say I'm going to make
n observations, it's
all I have time for.
The week is over.
I'm going on vacation
next week.
I've got to stop this test.
I've got to write my paper.
Take the end test.
You write your paper.
And what do you do?
You go through the optimal
tests the best you can.
And what you find is given H
equals 1, an error is going to
occur if the sum of random
variables, namely the
log-likelihood likelihood ratio,
exceeds the logarithm
of your threshold.
OK, this is whatever threshold
you decide to establish.
And we showed before that the
probability that S sub n is
greater than or equal to log of
the threshold is evaluated
as E to the n times this
quantity right here.
The probability of error
given H equals 1 is
this quantity here.
Probability of error given H
equals 1 is the probability
that the data looks like
H equals 0 was a right
hypothesis.
In other words, that you crossed
the threshold at plus
alpha, instead of crossing
the threshold at beta.
Excuse me.
We have too many cases
here we're looking
at, so it gets confusing.
What I'm looking at here is
the probability that the
log-likelihood ratio exceeds
this threshold data, whatever
we set beta to be.
Eta is set, depending on the
cost of making errors of both
types on our a priori beta,
if we have any and
all of those things.
And the probability of error
given H equals 1 is this
quantity here, which has the
threshold in it over there.
We've looked at that a number
of times in a lecture.
We looked at it in
chapter one.
And then those, we looked
at it in chapter seven.
And you calculate it by taking
this moment generating
function, drawing attention to
it at the point where slope
natural log of eta
divided by n.
And then you take where
it comes in to this
vertical axis here.
And that's the exponent of the
error of probability when
hypothesis 1 is correct.
Now, if the hypothesis is H
equals 0 instead, at that
point with H equals 0, the
expected value of this
log-likelihood ratio is
going to be positive.
The situation is going to be a
curve that comes over here,
comes back at some point here.
And what we've showed is that
this curve is just a
translation of this
curve by 1.
OK, namely if you calculate the
moment generating function
for H equals 0, you get the same
thing that we got before.
I'm not going to go through
all the details of this.
Now you have 0 here
instead of 1.
Over here you're going
to have just minus r.
And over here you're going
to have 1 plus r.
So this whole thing is
translated by 1.
The action happens here.
But if you translate it by 1
over in this direction, what
happens is the error
of probability is
determined by this.
It's this.
The exponent is this point right
here, gamma 1 of r0 plus
1 minus r0, log of eta over n.
And the r0 was again determined
by this point at
which the slope is equal
to log eta over n.
We did that before.
Then I want to make clear you
understood it, because to
really understand it, you have
to go through the arithmetic
yourselves at least once.
And you can do that easily by
following the notes, because
it does it in almost
excruciating detail.
So that's the argument
you get.
We had this idea before, of the
Neyman-Pearson principle,
which says you don't assume
a priori probabilities.
You look at the probability of
making an error as being a
trade off between the error you
make when H is equal to 1
and the error you make
when H is equal to 0.
In terms of the Chernoff
bound, this
trade off is very clear.
As you change the exponent that
you want to get under H
equals 1, this point moves.
The tangent then moves.
And the exponent over
here moves.
So you have this inverted
seesaw.
And the exponent for one kind
of error is over here.
And the exponent for the other
kind of error is over there.
Then the next thing we said
was this is really stupid,
unless you're going on
vacation this Friday.
If you're not going on vacation
this Friday, if
you're really serious about
making the right decision,
then what you're going to do is
keep on making observations
until you're pretty
sure you're right.
Now somebody at the end of the
lecture last time pointed out
something, which says that when
you do experiments and
you keep on making observations
until you get the
data that you want, there's
something very
unethical about that.
Is this that kind of
unethical behavior?
Or is this really valid?
Well, I claim this is valid,
because what we're doing when
we're doing sequential testing
is we're deciding what we're
going to do ahead of time.
Namely, we've decided what we're
going to do is we're
going to continue testing until
we cross a threshold and
threshold gives us a suitable
probability of error.
So we're not cooking
the books at all.
What we're doing is we're
following this preset
procedure we've set up.
And the only question is can
we get a very small error
probability by using a smaller
number of observations on the
average than what we
need otherwise?
Put it in terms of a
communication system.
One kind of communication
system, you have to send some
data from one point
to another.
You're not going to get
any feedback on it.
You've got to get the data
through the first time.
It's got to be right.
What are you going to do?
You're going to send this data
a very large number of times
or use a very powerful coding
technique on it.
And by time it gets through,
you're going to be very sure
you're right.
Now a much better procedure, and
the thing which is used in
almost all communication
systems, and the thing which
we use as human beings all the
time, and the thing which
control people use all the time,
the thing which almost
everybody uses, because most of
us have common sense if we
spend some time trying to do
these things, is instead of
trying to get it right the first
time, we try little bit
to get it right the
first time.
And we make sure that if we
don't get it right the first
time, we have some way of
finding out about it and
getting it right the
second time.
And in the scientific way of
looking at it, what we do is
we decide ahead of time exactly
what our procedure is
going to be for making
repetitions--
something called ARQ in
communication systems, which
means automatic repeat
request.
It's automatic, which means
you don't try to make your
decision depending on whether
you'd like to receive this 0
or like to receive a 1.
You make the decision ahead of
time that if you have a clean
enough answer, you're
going to accept it.
If it looks doubtful, you're
going to send it over again.
That's exactly the same sort
of thing we're doing here.
OK, when we do that, given H
equals 1, we again have this S
sub n as a function of
n as a random walk.
It's a sum of IID random
variables and
conditional on H equals 1.
You have a random walk.
Conditional on H equals 1, you
have a negative slope on this
random walk.
The random walk starts out and
on the average is going to go
down, and it's going to continue
going down forever.
And if you're looking for
across some positive
threshold, if it doesn't cross
it pretty soon, it's not going
to cross it.
But anyway, we have a test
which said we have some
positive threshold.
We have some negative
threshold.
If we ever cross the positive
threshold, we say
H is equal to 0.
If we ever cross the negative
threshold, we say
H is equal to 1.
And then we're done with it.
OK, now, let me give you another
argument why that
makes sense.
I gave you one argument
last time.
I'll give you another
argument this time.
If S sub J is greater than or
equal to 0, we're going to
decide that 0 is the
correct hypothesis.
If H equals 1 is the correct
hypothesis, then we're going
make an error when S
sub J is greater
than or equal to alpha.
If S sub J is less than or equal
to the beta, we're going
to decide H equals 1.
And conditional on H equals 1,
an error is made if SJ is
greater than or equal
to alpha.
Conditional on H equals 0, an
error is made if SJ is less
than or equal to beta.
OK, so the probability of the
error conditional on H equals
1 is the probability that S sub
J is greater than or equal
to alpha, given H equals 1,
which is less than or equal to
E to the minus alpha or star.
This is the thing that
we said before.
r star is the root
of gamma of r.
And gamma of r is
equal to this.
OK, so, let's just make life a
little easier for ourselves
assume that our a priori
probabilities are each 1/2.
This is also called maximum
likelihood decision.
You take this likelihood ratio,
and you just decide on
the basis of the likelihood
ratio.
OK, then at the end of trial
end, the probability of H
equals 0 given Sn divided by the
probability of H equals 1
given Sn, the a prioris
cancel out.
It is just E to the S sub n.
That's what it is.
It's the likelihood ratio.
S sub n is the log-likelihood
ratio.
So this is what it is.
If you now take probability of H
equals 0 on probability that
H equals 1 given S of
in, this equation
becomes this equation.
And then the probability of H
equals 1 given S sub n is just
E to the minus Sn over 1
plus E to the minus Sn.
Now if Sn is a large number, E
to the minus Sn is going to be
totally trivial.
And the probability that
H equals 1 given Sn is
essentially E to the minus Sn.
It means when you can choose
different values of n, this
very directly gives you
a control on what the
probability of error is.
The probability of error is
essentially E to the minus Sn.
So if you choose a threshold
alpha, what you're doing is
you're guaranteeing that the
probability of error cannot be
less than E to the
minus alpha.
OK, so this is more than just
talking about averages.
This is saying if you use a
threshold rule, then what
you're doing is guaranteeing
that the probability of error
is never going to be less
than this quantity
of specified here.
OK, we saw last time the cost of
choosing alpha to be large
is that you have to make a very
large number of trials,
at least given H equals 0.
Why don't I worry about
the number of trials
for H equals 1?
I mean, it's nothing to be
thought through here.
If my thresholds are large,
my probability of
error is very small.
The expected values of things
for very large log-likelihood
ratios are determined almost
entirely by H equals 0.
H equals 1 sometimes.
You sometimes make a mistake,
because it's something very,
very unusual.
But that has very little
influence on the expected
number of tests you're making.
So what happens then is the
expected number of tests you
make under the hypothesis
that H is equal to 0--
now we're using Wald's equality
rather than Wald's identity--
it's equal to the expected
value of S sub J given H
equals 0, divided by the
expected value of Z,
given H equals 0.
Z is the log-likelihood
ratio of one trial.
This is just Wald's
equality with this
condition thrown into it.
Now what's the expected value
of SJ given H equals 0?
It's essentially alpha, and if
you want to be more careful,
it's alpha plus the expected
overshoot given H equals 0.
And that's divided by the
expected value of Z,
given H equals 0.
This is the answer
we got last time.
So the number of tests you have
to make, if you set a
positive threshold alpha, is
essentially the number of
tests you have to make when
the hypothesis is equal 0.
So the funny thing which is
happening here is that as you
change alpha, you're changing
the probability of error for
hypothesis H equals 1.
And you're changing the number
of tests you're going to have
to do when H is equal to 0.
When you change beta, it's
just the opposite.
So that when you change beta, if
you make beta a very large
negative, you have to make an
enormous number of tests under
the circumstance that
H is equal to 1.
But you might make an error
when H is equal to 0.
So the trade off is between
number of trials under one
hypothesis, error of probability
under the other
hypothesis.
That's almost all we wanted to
say about Wald's identity.
There's one other huge thing
that we want to talk about.
If you take the first two
derivatives of Wald's identity
at r equals 0, you get some
interesting things coming out.
I mean, Wald's identity, you
can use it any value
of r you want to.
And when you use it for a large
value of r, you that an
interesting result about
large deviations.
When you use it at a small value
of r, you get something
more about typical cases.
So looking at it at r equals 0,
what you want to do is you
want to take the derivative
with respect
to r of Wald's identity.
This expected value in here
we know is equal to 1.
It's equal to 1 whatever
value of r we choose.
And therefore, when we take
the derivative of this, we
have to get 0.
But we also want to take
the derivative of it
to see what we get.
So when you take the derivative
of this quantity
here and you don't worry
about what exists and
what doesn't exist--
you have to take the
derivative here--
so you get an S sub J there.
You take the derivative
here, you get a
gamma prime of r there.
If you get SJ minus J times
gamma prime of r, and this E
to the what have you
just sits there.
You take the derivative of E
to something, you never get
rid of the E to something.
You just get piled up stuff
in front of it.
OK, so when we evaluate that at
r equals 0, what happens?
Well, what's the value of
the gamma prime of 0?
It's the expected
value of X, yes.
And this quantity here is all
equal to 1, so we can forget
about that.
When r is equal to 0,
this is equal to 0.
When r is equal to 0, gamma
of r is equal to 0.
So this whole thing
in here is 0.
So E to the 0 is 1.
So we've got a 1 there.
We got expected value of
S sub J minus J times X
bar is equal to 0.
What is that?
That's Wald's equality.
So Wald's equality falls out of
the Wald's identity as what
happens as the derivative
of Wald's identity
that r equals 0.
Well, since we're so successful
with that, let's go
on and take another
derivative.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I guess you want the
final equal to 0 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, the final equal
to 0 comes from the fact that
this quantity here that you're
starting with is equal to 1
for all values of r.
Therefore, I want to take
the derivative with
respect to r, I get 0.
So that's one equation.
The other thing is I just go
through the mechanics of
taking the derivative.
OK, so let's try to take
the second derivative.
Take the second derivative by
taking the derivative of the
first derivative.
And what happens is then is this
quantity in here I get an
extra term of that sitting
over there.
And along with that, I get the
derivative of this with
respect to r.
I should probably have written
that down there but since I
didn't, let me see
if I can do it.
I get the expected value of SJ
minus J gamma prime of r.
And this quantity
is squared now,
because I have this there.
I'm taking the derivative of
this term with respect to r.
And also, I have to take the
derivative of this with
respect to r.
So that gives me minus J times
gamma double prime of r.
And all of this times E to the
r SJ minus J gamma of r.
Now I want to evaluate
this at r equals 0.
Evaluating this at r equals
0, this term goes away.
So I wind up with the expected
value of SJ minus J gamma
prime of r where minus J
gamma double prime of
r is equal to 0.
Well, this doesn't look bad.
But if you try to use it if you
expand this term here, you
get a term the expected value of
S of J times J. And you can
struggle with that.
And it's ugly.
That's very ugly.
But if you now say, if
we have a mean we
can use Wald's equality.
It tells us what we
want to know.
If we don't have a mean, then
Wald's equality doesn't tell
us anything.
But this is going to
tell us something.
So we're going to make the
assumption here that r is
equal to 0 and X bar
is equal to 0.
And if X bar is equal
to 0, gamma prime of
0 is equal to 0.
And gamma double prime of 0 is
equal to sigma squared of X.
So you do all of that.
What you get is the expected
value of S sub J squared minus
sigma X squared of
J is equal to 0.
This is the same kind
of thing that we
got from Wald's equality.
From Wald's equality, it didn't
tell us anything.
It just gave us a relationship
between the expected value of
S sub J and expected
value of J. This is
doing the same thing.
It's giving us a relationship
between the expected value of
S sub J squared and the expected
value of J. So we get
the same kind of quantity.
It's doing the same
thing for us.
Now you look at this for a 0
means simple random walk.
Now you would have thought
before you started to take
this class that a simple random
walk with mean 0 was
the simplest thing
in the world.
And we've seen by looking at
that it really isn't all that
simple, that you come play these
silly games like you can
gamble forever, where with
probability 1/2 you lose $1,
with probability 1/2
you win $1--
perfectly fair game.
And with probability one, you
to make $1 out of that, and
quit and go home.
And since you to make $1 out of
it, and quit and go home,
you can then quickly come
back again and it again.
You can make $2.
You can make $10.
You can make $1,000.
You can make $1 million
with probability 1.
So the simple random walk
is no longer simple.
It becomes puzzling.
But Wald's identity is dealing
with two thresholds, one of
alpha and one at beta.
When we apply this and you
observe it as a simple random
walk, where you either go up
by 1 or go down by 1, each
with probability 1/2, the
mean of X is 0 and the
variance of X is 1.
So this quantity here is 1.
You can then play games with
what the probability is that
you hit the upper threshold and
the probability that you
hit the lower threshold.
I mean, it's done in the text.
You don't have to take
my word for it.
And when you do that, what you
find is the expected value of
J is equal to minus
beta times alpha.
Theta is a negative number,
remember, so this is expected
value of J is the magnitude
of theta times the
magnitude of alpha.
Now that's a little bizarre, but
then you think about it a
little bit.
You think what happens.
And this is really exact.
I mean, this isn't an
approximation or anything.
If alpha is very large, and
beta is very large and
negative, and you play this
random walk game, you're going
to fluctuate a long time.
You're going to disperse
slowly.
according to the square root
of n, or the number
of tests you take.
So the amount of time it takes
you until you get way out to
these thresholds should be--
to the namely the value
that n has to have--
roughly the square of alpha
when beta and alpha
are both the same.
This is something more
general than that.
It says that if Sn, the
stop-when-you're-ahead game,
we make alpha equals 1, the
expected value of J depends on
what the lower threshold is.
And that suddenly makes sense,
because what that's saying is
if we have a lower threshold at
10, an upper threshold at
one, then most of the
time you win.
But when you lose,
you lose $10.
When you win, you win, $1.
When you set a lower threshold
at 100, when you
lose, you lose $100.
When you win, you win $1.
And suddenly, that
stop-when-you're-ahead game
does not look quite as
attractive as it did before.
What you're doing is taking a
chance where you're probably
going to win of winning $1, and
you're risking your life's
assets for it, which doesn't
make too much sense anymore.
OK this, I think, it gives you
a better idea of what's going
on on the simple random walk
than anything else I've seen.
So it's time to start talking
about martingales.
A martingale, like most of the
other things we've been
talking about in the
course, is a
sequence of random variables.
This is a more general kind of
sequence than most of them.
Almost all of the processes
we've talked about so far have
been the kinds of things you can
sort of get your hands on.
And this is defined very
abstractly in terms of a
peculiar property that it has.
And then the peculiar property
it has is the expected value
as the nth term, in this thing
called a martingale,
conditional on knowing the
values of all the previous
values, expected value of Z sub
n given the value of Z and
minus 1, Z and minus 2, all the
way down to Z1 is equal to
Z sub n minus 1.
Namely, the expected value here
is what you had there.
The word martingale comes from
gambling, where gamblers used
to spend a great deal of time
trying to find gambling
strategies when to stop, when to
start betting bigger, when
to start betting smaller, when
to do all sorts of things, all
sorts of strategies for how
to lose less money.
Let me put it that way, because
you rarely find that
opportunity where you can
play a fair game.
But if you play a fair game,
martingales are what sort of
rules on that.
And what that says is if you
play this game for a long
time, your capital is
Z sub n minus 1.
This says, figure expected
capital after you
play one more time.
No matter what strategy you use,
your expected capital is
going to be the same as
was as the actual
capital the time before.
If this is too abstract for you,
and it's too abstract for
me half the time, because I look
at this, and I say, gee,
that's not much of a
restriction, is it?
What we're talking about is
expected values here.
But it's more than that, because
it's saying for every
choice of sample value for all
of these things, none of them
make any difference, except
the last one.
And that's what happens
in gambling.
It doesn't make any difference
how your capital has gotten to
the point where it is
at time n minus 1.
You make a bet in a fair bet,
and what you win is solely a
function of what you've bet,
if the game is fair.
And that's what this
is saying.
So when you write it out this
way, the expected value of Zn,
given that 1, the random
variable Zn minus 1 has a
particular value Zn minus 1.
You started out with
a particular value.
It says that expected value
is equal to what you
said at the last time.
And this is true for all sample
values Zn minus 1 down
to Z1, which is why it's a much
stronger statement than
it appears to be.
now there's a lemma.
I want to talk about that a
little bit, because it's a
good time to get you
used to what these
expected values mean.
For martingale, the expected
value of Zn given Zi, Zi minus
1, all the way down to Z1.
This expected value is
equal to Z sub i.
In other words, it's not only
that your expected capital,
given all of the past, is equal
to what you had on the
last time instant.
If you're not given anything
for 100 years back, and all
you know is what your capital
was 100 years ago, and if we
think we're playing a fair game
all of this time, which
is of course always a question,
the expected value
of what we have now, conditional
on everything from
100 years back through
recorded history, is
just that last term.
In other words, it's the same
kind of isolation of the past
from the future as we had
with Markov change.
With Markov change, remember,
it's only what happens at one
instant, given what happens a
one instant, it makes the past
independent of the future.
Here it's not quite that way,
because the past and the
future are separated only in
terms of the details of the
past, and the expected
value the future.
It says expected value of Z sub
n given all of the details
of the past, no matter what the
details of the past are,
the effective value of Zn is
equal to the actual value at
times Z sub i.
So I want to improve this for
you, and I warn you you're not
going to follow this proof.
And that's part of the reason
for me to do it, because I
want you to go back to Chapter
1 and think that through.
Because in dealing with
martingales, you have to think
this through.
Because if you don't think it
through, you're stuck with
this notation all
the way through.
And if you try to use this
notation with martingales,
this is nice notation when you
get confused, but you don't
want to use it all the time.
So you have to be able to go
through arguments like this.
What I want to show is that if
E to the Z3, given Z1 and Z2
is equal to Z2, then one special
case of this lemma is
that expected value of Z3
given Z1 is equal to Z1.
And how do we show that?
Well, what we do is we use this
law complete expectation.
Well, first we remember the
expected value of an arbitrary
random variable X is the
expected value of the expected
value of X given Y. Now
what does that mean?
The expected value of the random
variable X, given Y, is
a random variable.
It's a random variable which
depends on Y. That's a
function of the sample value of
Y. Namely, if you look at
this quantity up here,
expected value of X
given Y equals 1.
Expected value of X
given Y equals 2.
given Y equals 3.
We have all of these
values here.
We have a probability
measure on it.
This is a random variable,
which is a function of Y.
You've averaged that over X,
but you're left move why
because of the conditioning
here.
So this quantity in here is now
a function of Y. So when
we take this equation and we
add the conditioning on Z1,
namely, this is being
used for Z3 and Z2.
Expected value of Z3 is equal to
the expected value over Z2
of the expected value of Z3
given Z2, whole thing
dependent on Z1.
OK, so what it says is this
expected value is the expected
value of the expected value of
Z3 condition on Z2 and Z1.
This quantity here as
a function of what?
That's a random variable.
It's a function of what
random variables?
AUDIENCE: Z2, Z1.
PROFESSOR: Z1 and Z2, yes.
So this is a function
of Z1 and Z2.
What value is it as a function
of Z1 and Z2?
It's just equal to Z2.
So this quantity
in here is Z2.
so we're asking what's expected
value of Z2 given Z1.
And by definition of martingale,
it is equal to Z1.
Now I imagine about half you
could follow that, and half of
you couldn't, and half of
you sort of followed it.
This is a kind of argument we'll
be using all the way
through on this stuff.
So make sure you
understand it.
I mean, once you get
it, it's easy.
And you can apply it in
all sorts of places.
So it's worth doing it.
In the same way, you can
follow the same kind of
argument through the expected
value Z sub i plus 2, using
this total expectation
based on Zi plus 1.
And you go through
the whole thing.
When you go down to i equals 1,
it says the expected value
of z is equal to the expected
value of Z1.
If you want to become wealthy,
have a wealthy parent, who
leads to a lot of money
20 years ago.
That's the easiest way to make
a million dollars is to start
out with 2 million dollars
is the way that
some people put it.
OK, let's have some simple
examples a martingales.
One of them is a zero-mean
random walk.
Mainly, what I'm trying to do
here is to show you this
martingales are really pretty
general things.
And since there are many very
general theorems that hold for
all martingales, you can then
apply them to all of these
special cases, which
is kind of neat.
To have a zero-mean random walk,
let Z sub n be the sum
of X1 plus Xn and the X sub
i's are IID and zero mean.
The fact that they're IID
makes it a random walk.
The fact that there's zero mean
makes it a special zero
mean random walk, and the
expected value of Z sub n,
given Zn minus 1.
All the way back, Zn now
is Xn plus Zn minus 1.
OK, Zn is the sum of all
these random variables.
So you get up n minus 1 of them,
and then you add the
last one in.
So it's Zn minus 1 plus Xn, so
its expected value of Xn plus
Zn minus 1, given all the
stuff before that.
The expected value of Xn, given
all this stuff, is what?
Xn is independent of all the
other X's, therefore it's
independent of all
the earlier Z's.
And therefore, that's just
expected value of Xn.
So we have the expected value of
Zn minus 1, given Zn minus
1 back to Z1.
What's expected value of Zn
minus 1, given Zn minus 1?
Well, it's Zn minus 1.
That's no problem there.
So this is 0.
So this is equal to Zn minus
1, as it's supposed to be.
All of these things you ought
to go back and think them
through yourself.
Because the first time you look
at martingales, all of
this stuff, it's all pretty
easy, but it all looks a
little strange at first.
The next one is sums
of arbitrary
dependent random variables.
They're not quite arbitrary.
Suppose you have a sequence of
random variables, X sub i, i
greater or equal to 1.
And they satisfy the expected
value of Xi, given all the
earlier X of i's
is equal to 0.
It's similar to what
a martingale is.
But here, we're just saying
the Xi's all have expected
value of 0.
And Zn, the sum of these,
has to be a martingale.
And I'm not going to write
all a proof of that.
I mean, this proof is really
the same as this proof.
This is really a pretty
important thing, because given
any martingale, you can always
look at the partial sums
between the terms of
the martingale--
namely, given Z1, Z2,
up to Z sub n.
You can always look
at Z2 minus Z1.
You can look at Z3 minus Z2.
You could at Z4 minus
Z3, and so forth.
And each of the Z's is
just the sum of those
other random variables.
So given any martingale in the
world, you can always define
the set of arbitrary depending
random variables would satisfy
this rule here.
So Zn, in this case,
is a martingale.
And if Zn is a martingale, you
can always define a set of
random variables, which
satisfy this property.
I think it's almost easier to
see what a random variable
really has to do with gambling,
which is where it
started, by looking at this.
This is not your capital
at time n.
This is how much you win
or lose at time i.
And what it's saying is your
winnings or losings at time i
has zero mean independent of
everything in the past.
In other words, in a fair game,
you can bet whatever you
want to and depending on what
you bet, that's the expected
amount you get on that trial.
And that's what this says.
This says essentially, you're
applying a fair game.
So martingales really have
to do is fair games.
If you can find fair games,
why, that's great.
But we always look for games
where we have an edge.
But what you want to avoid
is games where Las
Vegas has an edge.
OK so, that's a general one.
Here's an interesting one,
because I think this is an
example which you can use.
I mean, in any field you
study, there are always
generic examples, which can be
used to generate counter
examples to any simple thing
you might want to think of.
And this is to me the most
interesting one of those for
martingales.
Suppose that Xi is the product
of two random variables--
one is either plus 1 or minus 1,
each with probability 1/2.
And the other one, Y sub i is
anything it wants to be.
I don't care what Y sub i is.
Y sub i is non-negative, might
as well make it non-negative.
I don't care about it.
I don't care how it's related
to all the other Y sub i's.
All I want is the that the U sub
i's are all independent of
all the Y sub i's.
And what happens then?
I take the expected value of X
sub i, give it anything in the
past, and what do I get?
U sub i is independent
of Y sub i.
And therefore, the expected
value of U sub i times Y sub i
is expected value of U sub
i, which is what--
plus 1 or minus 1 of probability
1/2 each.
The expected value of U
sub i is equal to 0.
That makes expected value
of X sub i of 0
whatever the past is.
So you automatically
have the--
I don't know what to call in
them, the terms between the
terms of a martingale--
the interarrival terms,
so to speak.
I mean, it's like those
for a renewal process.
Those terms always
have mean 0.
And therefore, the sums of
these turn out to be this
simple kind of martingale.
So that's a nice martingale to
use as counter examples for
almost anything.
The next one is product
for martingales.
Product for martingales are
things we use quite a bit too,
because now when we're using
generating functions, we're in
the habit of multiplying
things together.
And that's a useful
thing to do.
So the expected value of Z to
the n, given Z to the n minus
1, now to Z1, where Zn is
this product of terms.
OK, Z sub n then is equal to
Xn times Z sub n minus 1,
which is what we're
doing here.
Expected value of Zn conditional
on the past is the
expected value of Xn times Zn
minus 1, conditional on the
past, Xn and Zn minus 1.
Oh, the expected value of Xn
for any given value of Zn
minus 1, all the way back,
is just the expected
value of X sub n.
So we have expected value of X
sub n times the expected value
of Z sub n minus 1, given
Zn n minus 1 down to Z1.
So that's just Zn minus 1.
Ah, the missing quantity,
fortunately I wrote it here.
The X sub i's are unit means
random variables.
And they're IIDs.
They're independent
of each other.
And since the X sub i's are
independent of each other, X
sub n is independent
of Xn minus 1, all
the way back to X1.
Zn minus 1 back to Z1
is a function of Xn
minus 1, down to X1.
So Xn is independent of all
those previous Z's also.
That's why I could split
this apart in this way.
And suddenly I wind up with
Zn n minus 1 again.
So product form martingales
work.
Special form of product
form martingales--
this again is favored counter
example for when you can and
can't get around with
going to limits and
interchanging limits.
And it's a simple one.
Suppose that X sub i's
are IID, as in
the previous example.
And they're [INAUDIBLE]
probably 2 or 0.
I mean, this is a game
you often play--
double or nothing.
You start out with dollar.
You play the game.
If you win, you get $2.
If you lose, you're broke.
If you win, you play your $2.
If you win again, you have $4.
If you lose, you're broke.
You play again.
If you win, you have $8.
If you lose again,
you're broke.
So the probability that Z sub n,
which is your capital after
n trials, is equals to 2 to the
n, namely you've won all n
times, is 2 to the minus n.
And every other instance
you've lost.
So the probability that Zn is
equal to 0 is 1 minus 2
to the minus n.
So for each n, if you calculate
the expected value
of Z sub n, it's equal to 1.
Namely, with probability 2 to
the minus n, your capital is 2
to the n, so that's 1.
With all the other probability,
you have nothing.
So your expected value of Z sub
n is always equal to 1.
That's what this product
form martingale says.
And this is a product
form martingale.
However, the limit as n goes to
infinity of Zn is equal to
0 with probability 1.
If you play double or nothing,
eventually you lose.
And then you're wiped out.
In other words, there's no real
purpose to playing the
game, because eventually
you lose.
If you're playing with somebody
else, and they're
playing double or nothing, then
of course you get their
money eventually.
Or you go broke and the bank
that you bank at fails, and
all that stuff.
We won't worry about that.
OK, but the point of this is
that the limit as n goes to
infinity of Zn is equal to 0.
And the limit of the expected
value of Z sub
n is equal to 1.
And therefore, the limit of Zn
and the expected value of the
limit of Zn.
The expected value of the
limit of Zn is 0.
The limit as expected value
of Zn is equal to one.
So this is a case where you
can't interchange limit and
expectation.
It's an easy one to keep in
mind, because we all know
about playing double
or nothing.
Might as well define
submartingales and
supermartingales.
Because the first thing to know
about them is they're
like martingales, except
they're defined with
inequalities.
And for a submartingale, the
expected value of Zn, given
all the previous terms,
is greater than or
equal to Zn minus 1.
So submartingales go up.
Supermartingales are
the opposite.
Supermartingales goes down.
What else could you expect from
a mathematical theory?
Things that should
go up, go down.
go down, go up.
Only thing you have to remember
about submartingales
and supermartingales is you
figure out what terminology
should have been used, and you
remember the terminology they
use was the opposite of
what they should use.
I don't know whether I've
ever seen stupider
terminology than this.
And someone once explained the
reasoning for it, and the
reasoning was stupid too.
So there's no excuse
for that one.
We're only going to refer to
submartingales in what we're
doing, partly because that's
where most of the
neat results are.
And the other thing is if
you have to deal with a
supermartingale, what you might
as well do is instead of
dealing with a sequence--
Z1, Z2--
deal with the sequence minus
Z1, minus Z2, and so forth.
And if you change the sign on
all the terms, then you change
supermartingales into
submartingales and vice versa.
You don't really have to
deal with both of them.
Let me talk briefly about an
inequality that I'm sure most
of you heard of.
How many people have heard
of Jensen's Inequality?
Maybe half of you,
so not everyone.
Well, it's one of the
main work horses
of probability theory.
Even though we haven't seen it
yet this term, you will see it
many times.
So what a convex function is.
A convex function in simple
minded terms is something, a
convex function from r into r.
A real value convex function
is a function which has a
positive second derivative
everywhere.
So it curves down and
comes back up again.
Since you also want to talk
about functions which don't
have second derivatives,
you want something more
general than that.
So you go from derivatives.
You go back to your
high school ideas,
and you draw a picture.
And function is convex.
If all the tangents to the curve
lie not strictly below,
but all the tangents can curve
lie beneath the curve, so
wherever you draw a tangent,
you get something which
doesn't cross the curve.
Magnitude of X is a convex
function of X. Magnitude X as
a function of X looks
like this.
You go down or up.
And all tangents to this, this
goes off to infinity and this
goes off to infinity.
So there's no way to
get something like
that in this tangent.
So you have one tangent here.
You have a bunch of tangents
along here.
And you have one
tangent there.
And they all lie below
the curve.
So X bar is a convex
function too.
And Jensen's Inequality says if
H is convex, and if Z is a
random variable, it has finite
expectation, then H of the
expected value of Z is less than
or equal to the expected
value of H of Z. You can
interchange expected value and
function with inequality
like this, if
the function is convex.
Now, why is this true?
You can see why it's true
automatically, if you're
dealing with a random variable
that has only two values.
If you have two values for
the random variable--
Z is a random variable here.
You have one variable here,
one value here, one sample
value here.
Look at what the expected
value of H of Z is.
The expected value of H of Z is
the expected value of this
and this with the appropriate
probability put in on it, so
at some point that lies
on the straight line
between here and there.
When you look at the H of the
expect the value, then you
find the expected value
along here.
You can think of finding it
along the straight line here.
And then it's that
point there.
So since the curve is convex,
the H of the expected value of
Z is there's always
a bunch of points.
Average them, which
lie on a straight
line beneath the curve.
And the expected value of H
of Z is taking the average
directly along the curve.
So you get this boosting
up everywhere.
It's like saying that the
absolute value of expected
value of Z is less than or equal
to the expected value of
the absolute value of Z.
And I think I will stop there
instead of going on, because
we had a lot of new
things today.
And somehow sequential detection
always wears one's
mind out in a short
period of time.
That should be enough.